[Musik]
nach unserem neuen schönen intro darf
ich euch jetzt hier recht herzlich
begrüßen zu einem neuen wunderschönen
morgen in unserer kleinen süßen
minecraft welt meine lieben freunde ihr
seht bereits im titel eingeblendet in
der heutigen episode kümmern wir uns
endlich um die kirche die dort hinten ja
steht ja und dafür solltest du auch mal
weg gehen ich bin euch direkt mal ganz
ganz fixiert time lab seine wir müssen
eine menge materialien besorgen so die
erste teil wird kann ich schon mal ganz
kurz unterbrechen denn die meisten
materialien die ich benötige habe ich
bereits die sache ist allerdings dass
ich da ich auf jeden fall noch mal in
unserer mühle der einigen rhein musste
der leuchtturm wunder wunder wunderschön
unsere insel darum sollte heute
allerdings nicht gehen sondern um die
tiere insel hier ich kann euch schon mal
ganz kurz zeigen wie ich mir das ein
bisschen vorgestellt habe ich werde den
weg der allerdings denke ich nicht hier
hin kurven lassen sondern hier so ein
bisschen drüber
das werde ich euch gleich allerdings
nochmal genau zeigen ich kann euch
jedoch schon mal ganz kurz die eben
zeigen wie ich das ganze ding hier bauen
möchte und zwar soll das hier in etwas
so stattfinden und dann hier vorne so
umgehen hier brauchen nämlich 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 dann gehen mit 201 bei 34 5 4
vorne eine um die ecke zack zack zack
zack zack ihr ein rum dann hier noch mal
ein zwei drei vier das bad schon viel
sport glaube ich aber so einfach sonst
habe ich aussehen und hier haben wir 1
2567 das passt auf jeden fall perfekt
die können auch mal 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 und
ich glaube das sollte dann doch so
passen auf jeden fall wird das hier in
etwa die kirche seien also so groß wie
die tatsächlich und die wird dann von
unserer insel hier vorne sehr geil
aussehen
die sache ist allerdings dass der
eingang zur kirche halt hier ist das ist
hier ein bisschen eng das heißt sie
müssen wir sind formeln dass der weg
dann hier vorne irgendwie so umgeht aber
das ging ja schon alles hinter euch
allerdings aber eine ganz kurze time lab
beziehungsweise zuallererst setzt sich
hier mal eben kurz die truhen hin so
dass wir unsere ganzen item sie am start
habe ich habe schon lesepult mitgenommen
ich habe auf meinem blog
von der willicher insel hinten
mitgenommen da ist ganz einfach die
sache dass sich die hierfür jetzt
benötige denn glocke passt einfach in
eine kirche wie faust aufs auge
jetzt kann ich das sprichwort über den
vieren fall müssen wir da hinten dann
neue glocke irgendwann hinhängen da
vorne hin die ja sonst und dann müssen
wir denen demnächst auch noch mal in das
ist so schön es ist so schön
ich kann ihre talk habe ich etwas
gedrückt
[Musik]
die meisten sachen haben wir jetzt
tatsächlich fertig meine lieben freunde
ihr seht schon hier vorne die kiste ist
ordentlich gefüllt wir brauchen
allerdings auch eine menge stein ziegel
und eine menge fichten heute die sache
ist allerdings ist hier fast gar nichts
gewachsen ist oder vornehmlich noch im
raum stehen lassen ich muss mir halt
noch unfassbar viele fichten holztreppen
für das dach basteln und dahingehend
auch noch eine menge stein ziegel mit
denen ich die ganze mauer am rand bauen
muss allerdings fangen wir damit jetzt
erst mal ganz kurz an und zwar geht die
sonne schön darunter
ich kann nichts dafür
wie soll ich das ein problem ich war
[Musik]
richtig wir bauen hier erst mal so ein
bisschen die stein ziegelmauer hin und
gehen dafür vier blöcke in die höhe und
das gleiche machen wir jetzt auch noch
in diese richtung hier und dann hier
auch wieder 123 454 rüber und das auch
vier blöcke hochziehen hier vorne gehen
wir ja zwei blöcke nochmal in die seite
reinen dass sie wird so ein bisschen der
vor eingang von der kirche und hier
vorne kommen dann so die bänke hin
hier an der seite machen wir ein paar
fenster hin dass ordnen wir nehmen mich
so an zack zack zack und hier oben auch
noch ich sehe auch meine stein ziegel
neigen sich dem ende zu und die sonne
geht unter
ich esse was es mit dem bus der
leuchtturm
[Musik]
hier oben führen nehmen wir jetzt auch
unsere stein ziegel dazwischen setzen
wir bruch steintreppen dass sie nachher
mit dem dach dann ganz cool aus und hier
unten setzen wir einzige treppen rein
und hier zwischen packen wir jetzt zum
bruchsteinmauern ich bin generell die
kombiniert das wird schon noch gut
aussehen auf der rückseite gehen wir nun
eine wenig anders vor das erste hier
bleibt jedoch erst mal gleich und zwar
hier vorne die bruchsteinmauern
dazwischen setzen hier vorne kommt man
auch weiße glasscheiben dazwischen
allerdings packen wir hier in die mitte
schein ziegelmauern damit dass so ein
bisschen so aussieht wissen mich nachher
von innen dann der altar von einer ecke
und hier oben drauf kommen nun
fichtenholz treffen denn hier geht das
dach so ein bisschen los die schüler
unter hier zwischen kommen nun
fichtenholz stufen und wir bauen uns
jetzt mal ganz kurz hier oben drauf denn
wir haben hier erst mal noch zwei
stressige vergessen sehe ich gerade
allerdings müssen wir uns jetzt hier
erstmal ein bisschen hoch bauen und das
dach fertig bauen bzw nicht fertig wir
fangen gerade erst an allerdings das
gleiche auch nochmal hier vorne von der
seite also hier ein hoch jetzt hier
vorne 12 412 und hier noch 12 der war
falsch hier vorne dem weg und zack die
sonne geht ganz groß unter das heißt ich
gehe mal eben schnell schlafen die sache
ist an alle die das jetzt eventuell
wieder
ich will halt auch mal früher schlafen
gehen wir klettern nun allerdings mal
ganz kurz wieder auf das dach hier drauf
und lassen jetzt 123 platz hier vorne
dann einen stein ziel hin und wieder ein
23 platz lassen denn das gleiche das
wiederholen wir jetzt auch hier für die
stellen jetzt können wir hier zwischen
fichten holztreppen setzen und hier eben
fichtenholz bretter das gleiche
wiederholen wir jetzt auch mal ganz kurz
eben auf der anderen seite denn das wird
jetzt unser dach sein und da wird sich
gleich herausstellen ob wir genügend von
dem ganzen fichtenholz haben denn den
ganzen apparat ziehen wir
selbstverständlich auf jeder seite noch
mal kurz hier hoch und auch nach innen
wird das ganze jetzt hier so weiter
gehen das habe ich auch bei meiner
villiger insel
bei den dächern so gemacht sobald wir
dann von jeder seite hier in der mitte
angekommen sind setzen wir hier 3 stein
ziegel in die mitte ein und hier auch
bei schweinen ziegen und die mit ein und
dazwischen ein fachbuch steinstufen so
dass das ganze dach dann so aussieht
zeigt euch das jetzt auch noch mal von
unten denn ich muss auch ganz kurz noch
einmal die weißen glasscheiben holen
also sieht das dach dann aus um mit den
glasscheiben machen wir jetzt hier vorne
das fenster rein nämlich einfach hier
vorne 5 in einer reihe und hier dann den
rest eben fertig machen
jetzt gehen wir noch eben schnell zur
anderen seite übernehmen unsere einzige
von den wir definitiv zu wenig haben und
müssen das ja auch noch mal ganz kurz
eben alles zu bauen so ich habe mir
jetzt noch eineinhalb sechs meerschwein
ziegel gemacht die weder davon schon die
kirche die wieder ein echter geil aus
und je vorne ist auch schon direkt ein
neuer fichtenholz baum gewachsen von
daher werden wir den auch mal ganz kurz
gesagt die ganze zeit fichtenholz baum
das ist einfach eine fichte und hier
vorne jetzt eine steintreppe und auch
hier vorne jetzt werden wir uns hier
abwechselnd mit stein ziegeln und
polierten an die sieht insgesamt acht
blöcke in die höhe hoch bauen und vorne
auf der anderen seite auch 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 das hier vorne wird nämlich der tower
so ein bisschen sein ich bin so dumm
dass ich hier immer so runter springt
hier vorne setzte es allerdings auch
noch polierten an die sieht hin und hier
auch darauf setzen wir stein ziegel
stufen genauso wie ich hier vorne und
auch auf dem ding hier vorne drauf so
hier jetzt einige bruchsteine einmal
hier jetzt muss ich konzept überspringen
hier vorne und dort vorne auch und hier
und hier daran auch mal eben und
dazwischen jetzt ein ziegel treppen die
ich hoffentlich jetzt richtig platzieren
werde die müssen nämlich in diese
richtung gibt zeigen das zimmer ein
bisschen dumm bei diesen treffen hier
gelöst hier vorne beim eingang bauen wir
uns als auch nochmal auf jeder seite 8
blöcke in die höhe mit dem bruchstein
und hier vorne auch noch mal eben einmal
kurz wieder runter bisschen falsch an
kriegen und zack und hier gucken
blöcke mal in die höhe und setzten hier
eine stein ziegel treppe hinunter wollen
wir uns dann eben mal ganz kurz wieder
ein bisschen hoch so dass wir hier auch
zwei bruchstelle draufsetzen können und
auch noch eine steintreppe dann nehme
ich hier zwei abstände und können jetzt
noch mal ganz kurz und schaufeln simons
kurz wieder runter bauen und hier unten
haben wir auch zwei abstände beim
eingang wo wir jetzt auch mal ganz kurz
die pflichten holztür hier wieder falsch
rum passieren werden so dass diese nach
innen rein geht und hier oben müssen
weil es auch dazwischen so ein bisschen
glas reinpacken nämlich hier und hier an
die seite nun allerdings die immer ganz
gut wieder abgebaut und dort
bruchsteinmauern hingesetzt das sieht
ein bisschen schöner aus mit den
glasscheiben hier vorne wird jetzt
allerdings ein bisschen kompliziert mit
den stein ziegel treppen die müssen wir
jetzt nämlich so hinsetzen jetzt einmal
ganz kurz hier hoch bauen die
schildkröte gerappt sich ja auch schon
die ganze drumherum
hier vorne muss jetzt ein so drauf nie
habe ich auch schon wieder direkt
falschen das so schwierig mit diesem
treffen
hier muss eine hin dann muss ich hier
vorne eine hin und hier vorne dran und
jetzt auf dieser seite muss ich jetzt
eine von unten so setzten dann haben wir
nämlich so etwas entspannten bogen um da
reinzugehen der sieht absolut scheiße
aus die schildkröte muss jetzt einmal
ganz kurz weg denn das hier bei euch
jetzt mal eben kurz ab und setze ich
hier bruchsteinmauern hin um hier
laternen darauf zu setzen dass wir auch
so ein bisschen beleuchtung haben wir
mehr eingehen wollen ich glaube
allerdings ist der eingang von ein
bisschen weiter weg vielleicht doch gar
nicht mehr ganz so scheiße aus da wir
hier vorne ja keinen eingang benötigen
setzen wird die stein ziegel treppe
direkt hier vorne hin an der seite dann
wieder bruchstein hoch und mit dem glas
können wir dann auch hier vorne direkt
anfangen also zack und hier vorne auch
noch eins drauf hier an den seiten dann
wieder hoch mit bruchsteinen hier vorne
dann wieder eine treppe die ich jetzt
allerdings von hier so setzen muss jetzt
mal ganz kurz sie wieder mit unserem
gerüst ecke erde hoch und hier auch noch
bruchsteine hin und dann ersetzen wir
hier an den seiten auch ganz kurz den
burg stein wieder durch bruchsteinmauern
die sonne es allerdings auch
untergegangen
deswegen gehen wir auch mal ganz schnell
schlafen und setzten hier vorne auch
wieder unser dach drauf
genauso wie vorne das wird allerdings
ein bisschen besser aussehen darf ich
hier nicht so eingeschränkt sind durch
die wand wie auf der anderen seite das
heißt hier vorne eine fichtenholz treppe
so hin und jetzt eine hier von der seite
und eine hier von der seite jetzt bauen
wir als allerletztes das gleiche nochmal
genauso hier auf der rückseite
zuvor nehmen wir uns allerdings auch ein
bisschen eichenlaub mit was ich mir
gerade hier vorne von dem bau
abgeschnitten habe vier stücken wenig
wir brauchen nur drei
die sollen nämlich hier zwischen sein
damit das ganze auch ein bisschen grün
aussieht und hier auf der rückseite wie
vorhin bereits gesagt das ganze jetzt
auch noch mal eben wiederholen so dass
es von der rückseite eins zu eins so
aussieht wie hier von der seite seite
heißt wenn die sonne so um gegenstände
rum leuchtet als nächstes kümmern wir
uns nun allerdings um die glocken region
hier vorne da gehen wir nämlich immer
auf jeder seite 4 in die höhe und dann
von außen hier steinmauern gesetz
beziehungsweise bruchsteinmauern immer
zwei in die höhe hier von jeder seite
habe ich mir gerade noch ein paar neue
gemacht eben an unserer werkbank darauf
platzieren wir jetzt ein ziegel treppen
und dazwischen bruchstein stufen und nun
hier oben noch mit steinen ziegeln ein
drei mal drei großes dach drauf hier
vorne mit unserem kleinen trip wird wenn
wir das ganze mal wieder abbauen und
hier nun eine kette dran und an die
kette kommt dann die glocke hier den
boden machen wir dann selbstverständlich
auch aus steinen ziegeln und jetzt
müssen wir noch mal ganz kurz nach oben
gehen denn da kommt natürlich noch einen
dach dran dafür habe ich nämlich auch
wieder natürlich fichtenholz bretter
hier am start und an die fichten heute
bretter setzen wir jetzt treppen
allerdings so abwechselnd auf jeder
seite und dann hier wie folgt weiter
nämlich dreimal dreißigsten holzbretter
in die mitte und dann hier außenrum zack
und noch mal 123 und zack und jetzt hier
nochmal zwei in die höhe hier mit
in die mitte dann so ein plus rein und
von dem plus an zwei nach oben und dann
setzen wir jetzt hier noch von jeder
seite eben kurz so fichtenholz treppen
dran und hier nun von der seite auch
nochmals verschönerung fichtenholz zäune
und dann muss ich mir jetzt noch mal
ganz kurz 123 leafs holen die habe ich
nämlich vorhin vergessen auf die
rückseite da hinten dran zu packen das
seht ihr jetzt auch direkt was ich meine
das habe ich mich auch auf der einen
seite hier gemacht auch kuba
sie steht direkt am wasser das ja auch
ganz nett ich glaube wenn sonic kirche
nicht existieren würde wäre ich auch
viel häufiger in gottesdiensten wenn ihr
einfach so richtig geil wären so ich
weiß nichts von fusionen kirche die so
gut da passen dann wahrscheinlich
maximal zehn leute werden nun setzen uns
allerdings an die inneneinrichtung und
müssen dafür den kompletten boden
erstmal abbauen also der ganze sand
kommt weg und wird ersetzt durch rote
wolle die sache ist allerdings dass die
sonne schon wieder untergeht das ist
unfassbar schön
wir gehen ganz kurz schlafen und ich
mach das kurz mit dem boden so sieht das
ganze auf jeden fall schon mal ein
bisschen mehr nach kirche aus hier vorne
setzen wir zwei so fichtenholz treppen
hin mit einer fichte neue stufe in die
mitte und an die seite 2 porzellan
sternchen und generell kommen jetzt hier
vorne erst mal die sitzbänke hin er ich
finde so sitzbänke in kirchen immer so
unfassbar unbequem
allerdings kommt hier vorne dann unser
altar hin mit einem lesepult und tabak
mehr treffer buch und feder darauf dass
theoretisch etwas einschreiben stelle
mir vor dass die bibel ist hier kommen
jetzt auf jeden fall noch zwei
fichtenholz druckplatten hin und jetzt
endlich zu unseren fichtenholz falsch
werden denn die sollen so ein bisschen
diese ja die heißt genau diese ablagen
für bücher und solche vorne darstellen
hier vorne kommen jetzt noch mal fünf
stein ziegel treppen hin und hier an den
rand nun fackeln sodass wir auch alles
ein bisschen ausgeleuchtet ich finde
laternen würden hier drin nicht so
richtig gut passen hier von oma kurz
fackeln drangesetzt allerdings nehmen
wir unsere laternen jetzt nochmal hier
für die mitte denn ich hier soll eine
laterne hin und hier vorne auf zack und
hier also hier gibt es auf jeden fall
ganz nice aus einer mir hier so die
beleuchtung so ein bisschen in der
kirche und jetzt müssen wir uns nur noch
um den weg zur kirche kümmern der soll
hier vorne so ein bisschen um die seite
umgehen hier zack zack zack zack und
dann von hier einfach war sie geradeaus
durch so dass er dann hier vorne an der
seite hoch geht das heißt dass hier noch
einmal
kurze weg der sand packe ich mal hier
vorne ich mach das mal eben ganz kurz
hier vorne nämlich unsere werke auch
noch mal eben kurz mit ich muss ja ich
hier an der seite dass man dem friedhof
auch noch mal so ein bisschen stützen
das kann ich jetzt gerade hier mal so
ein bisschen so erstmal noch
provisorisch machen allerdings werden
wir das demnächst auf jeden fall auch
noch machen und wenn das dann ja auch
alles erstmal zu gras wird damit das
auch ein bisschen besser aussehen das
ganze vielleicht neu zu bauen wenn ich
mir davon hab ich mir auch tatsächlich
dann doch ein bisschen zu viel geholt
die sache ist allerdings dass die kirche
jetzt erst mal fertig sie sieht schon
sehr sehr sehr sehr schön ausfindig und
dann kommt man quasi hier vorne vom
friedhof von unserem tierfriedhof rüber
hier an dem weg lang der allerdings hier
vorne dann auch erstmal weiter zu gras
wachsen muss und dann geht es quasi hier
runter an der seite beziehungsweise ich
glaube den könnten sogar noch ein
bisschen weiter hier drüber ziehen und
das dann hier irgendwie hoch geht also
beispielsweise ich ihr dann eben noch
ein bisschen erde hinsetzen und dann
geht es quasi hier irgendwie so hoch ich
glaube dass er ganz cool aus dann können
wir auch eine bruchstein stufe hin
packen
genauso haben wir auf unserer insel auch
gelöst und jetzt habe ich das gras nicht
verbunden
machen wir der nächsten folge darum
haben die behutsamkeit spitzhacke machen
ihr den weg hin und dann machen wir hier
vielleicht ein bisschen schon damit ein
bisschen lief hier vorne noch ein baum
darum dass wir vorne kann ich mal ganz
kurz abbauen da sollte ja ja und an der
stelle wirklich das heutige video dann
auch beenden ich muss mir trotzdem mal
eben kurzem ein brötchen schnappen und
zurück zu meiner insel fahren denn ich
möchte mir auf jeden fall die kirche
noch mal eben schnell von hier vorne
angucken denn das sieht glaube ich
extremen als aus hier vorne mit dem
leuchtturm auch sehr sehr sehr sehr wild
mit dem portal schwert das freut mich
extrem da wohl noch in die kommentare
geschrieben luca war doch mal das portal
schon das sage ich jetzt noch nicht ich
glaube die person die es geschrieben hat
die weiß eventuell was ich machen möchte
da oben sieht man es ein bisschen
allerdings ist das hier
die kirche die sieht sehr sehr sehr sehr
geil aus da bin ich sehr froh darüber
und das passt perfekt mit dem friedhof
dahinten von daher will ich an der
stelle das heutige video minecraft genug
hat jetzt auch beende meine lieben
freunde ich bin bei zweieinhalb stunden
aufnahmezeit das tut mir leid dass das
heutige video glaube ich dann
dementsprechend ein bisschen später kam
es sollte eigentlich gar nicht so lang
werden allerdings ihr wisst ja lieber
ein langes video und dann werde ich
fertig mit dem ziel und das sieht ja
auch schön aus deswegen lasse gerne
daumen hoch und ein video da wenn es
euch gefallen hat abonnierten kanäle
klickt auf die glocke um zukünftige
videos auf einem kanal nicht zu
verpassen
wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder und 20
uhr und ihr dürft wieder mal entscheiden
was ich machen soll
pauli mein gott kenne leute die so
komische verabschiedung machen aus san
francisco oder so auf wiedersehen
[Musik]